Russia's invasion is going backwards in
parts of Ukraine
powerful tank towed off the battlefield
like a plow
it's a very different route from the one
used to enter like this Railway
connecting Russia with Ukraine
nothing running now after Ukrainian
troops we captured territory right up to
the Border but they've not yet secured
the peace
this sign says that the board with
Russia is in that direction it's about
two and a half miles down the road the
ukrainians have retaken control of the
border crossing point but it's still
coming under direct Russian fire and
we've been told it's too dangerous to
head there at the moment
in the towns and Villages closest to
Russia an eerie quiet in between the
sporadic shelling
there are suspicions not everyone here
in vov chansk is sorry Russia's
occupation has ended
a soldier who's accompanying us is Keen
for the man to answer our questions
[Music]
foreign
it used to be the main police station
until the Russians came and outside what
was until just a few days ago a Russian
base here behind me that was a Russian
military checkpoint and on the floor
there are a number of old Russian
newspapers this one here dated the 9th
of August with a headline that rather
fittingly reads Ukraine promises
counter-offensive
the occupiers appeared to have
controlled by fear punishing those
sympathetic to Ukraine
is
this is the site police are
investigating the torture claims so he
weren't allowed inside
foreign
Village the soldier introduces us to his
family
they couldn't see each other during the
occupation making moments like these all
the more precious
the father shows us marks from where he
says he was detained and tortured with
electric shocks but not by the Russians
instead he says it was local policemen
who chose to collaborate with the
occupiers and wanted answers about a
theft
foreign
with the village back under Ukrainian
control those police officers apparently
fled to Russia but the sense of betrayal
lingers
debraham Sky News near the Ukraine
Russia border